hey this is really really compelling
video from CNN CNN's Don Lemon abruptly
ended his entire show seemingly 5
minutes early on CNN tonight when one of
the panelists Paris Denard who is one of
those elusive black Trump supporters
continued to say that the story that he
was participating in on Don lemons show
qualified as fake news and the
conversation was about the costs of
Trump and milania's travel and and the
associated costs of Melania being in New
York City and Trump going tomorrow Lagos
seemingly every weekend and Paris Denard
said this is faking news Don Lemon
didn't like it and he decided to shut
the whole thing down check it out I want
to bring in Paris now sorry to cut you
guys short but I want to get it all in
before if you have Paris what sure what
do you think is fake news this is this
is not this is not a new story let me
just tell you why the president is not
breaking any laws and he's not doing
anything it's not okay hold on let you
finish do you actually know what the
definition of fake news is what we're
doing right now no okay because this is
an you are the fake news because you are
on there and you're part of that no fake
noses when you let me explain the people
out there watching in you with fake news
is fake news is when you put out a story
to intentionally deceive someone and you
know that it is wrong I don't know of
anyone who has put out a story in the
mainstream media that I can think of
right now to that to intentionally
deceive anyone now people get things
wrong sources sometimes empty but no one
that I know is put out anything to
intentionally deceive someone this story
that we're doing right now is not to
intentionally deceive anyone we are
simply talking about the cost to keep a
president safe the Secret Service profit
and where the throne in the cause and if
they're and as Andre said and if there
are ways that we could you can may be
able to work on that to make it about
fiscally better for the American people
there is nothing fake about that please
stop it with that stupid talking point
that is a fake news story if you don't
want to participate in the news stories
on this network and then don't come on
and participate but don't call them fake
because you don't agree with them
go on Don this is a fake news story in
my opinion because the very much
everyone
thanks everyone thanks for watching have
a great weekend goodnight all Don Lemon
seeming genuinely upset there this is
actually an important story okay Trump
spent as much in one month on travel as
President Obama spent on average in an
entire year during his presidency and
Trump did it after slamming Obama for
vacationing slamming Obama for playing
golf which by the way Trump is done on
six of the first 31 days in the White
House and it's costing huge taxpayer
money so Don Lemon is right to say this
is not fake news but more broadly the
fake news thing must be fought against I
don't always agree with Don Lemon but
when I do I agree strongly Trump
supporters say anything they disagree
with or think is a negative narrative
for Trump is fake news period Trump
himself does this he's been convincing
his supporters that anything negative
about him is fake news and calling
legitimate news organizations fake news
is actually fake news actually I prefer
to call it propaganda news I mean I
could see if CNN was reporting something
that could come across as conspiratorial
right or there were anonymous sources
that he would tactically want to call it
fake news to kind of write it off
because that seems to be a good strategy
for him that's what gives him Pat's on
the back from the Trump administration
of course but I mean this is just a
plain fact the fact that he's spending
11 million dollars on travel expenses in
just his first month and continues to
vacation when he campaigned against
doing that
absolutely and anchors should shut
people down the second they hear those
people lying on the air there comes a
point where there's really nothing to be
gained by allowing a particular guest to
sit there and spew nonsense it doesn't
help the show it doesn't help the
audience and yes of course there's
political theater at CNN it exists at
many major news entities Jon Stewart did
a great job pointing that out in the
now-infamous crossfire segment from
years and years ago healthy skepticism
of news assertions is good but this must
be stopped and Don Lemon absolutely did
the right thing here although Don Lemon
has run with stories that I would find
fact-check worthy and he has been wrong
but to say that it's fake news is
implying something drastically different
altogether Gamefly is sort of like
Netflix for video games they have over
8,000 new and classic games for xbox one
Xbox 360 ps4 ps3 Wii and a bunch of
other platforms and you can play as many
games as you want for one monthly fee
and if you find some games you want to
keep you can buy them for a low used
price there's never any due dates or
late fees and our audience can get a
free 30-day trial at Gamefly offer.com
slash TDP s the games are shipped
directly to you with return envelopes
included there's no contracts and you
can rent games through the mobile app
get the free 30-day trial for the David
Pakman show audience and support our
show by going to Gamefly offer.com slash
TDP s